if you say something about me and I
don't get mad that mean I'm not
ready his response is his response is
telling me he ain't ready I would have
been like f excuse my French F sha and
Charles watch this for the rest of the
season that's how you respond cuz when
because because because actually when I
say certain things I'm egging you on to
see what you're going to do but the fact
that and again it's all about that look
he still ain't got that look today still
it's it's really like yo I want all
these guys to be great players and you
see this kid got so much talent but he's
a yo-yo guy cuz he's not in good shape
and I had to go through that early of my
career I couldn't play backto back games
until I lost 50 PBS and that's why he'll
get 35 one night and 15 the other night
because he can't sustain it and I hope
he gets in shape because we we thought
he was going to be the next big thing
and right now the jewelry still out